this whole idea actually gave me a
little bit of a tangential shock
yesterday which is that as this was
happening I said wow I can't believe
this is really happening in America and
I I had just signed up for some of the
AI programs because I'm just curious to
see how good the AI programs are so I
went to one of the AI programs and I
typed in Donald Trump as the defendant
in a courtroom full of kangaroos so
something to that effect I typed in one
or two prompts it was not very
complicated
and the AI spit out
an amazing courtroom image you know the
in that style of drawing that you see
from courtroom images of Donald Trump
sitting as a defendant
with a kangaroo with a little smirk on
his face sitting there as a juror
it's it's probably the most widely
shared political cartoon of yesterday
and I was able to spit it out I didn't
spit it out at all I just typed it in it
took like 30 seconds
so wow that was really really fast and
then
I came up with another even more
evocative and actually somewhat
disturbing political cartoon
and it told me a lot not just about the
the Trump trial told me not even just
this political moment it told me a lot
about what AI is about to mean for our
whole society so I made this little
political cartoon with a kangaroo in the
court okay then I said
now one of my other conclusions here is
that in New York you could indict a ham
sandwich so I said okay give me a give
me a ham sandwich that looks like Trump
whatever I wrote it wasn't all that much
more complicated than that and it spits
out
and if you're listening to this right
now you've got just go online look it up
later it's so shocking it's this
surreal photorealistic image of a
sandwich with a trump face in the ham
with his little pout and this blonde
eyebrows and the eyebrows and the hair
are made of cheese whiz and it's really
a brilliant piece of art
that this computer made
in like a minute
now this is going to put a lot of
artists out of work or it's going to
radically change the nature of artists
work it's going to change the nature of
political cartoons because the first two
political cartoons of this
Trump arraignment which is an historic
event we're just spit out by a computer
because I was goofing around within a
matter of minutes
but but this poses a real risk for
society broadly
because the trend we have seen in
society
over certainly the last 30 years but
really at a much longer time scale than
that
is a trend toward atomization
a trend away from communal activities
toward individual activities
so we don't have bowling leagues really
anymore we don't have the Lions Club
anymore I mean these things exist but
people just don't participate in them as
they used to people don't really go to
their churches anymore people are not as
involved in their communities anymore
people don't have a ton of kids anymore
and so they're they're just people don't
sit on their front porches anymore
they're more likely to sit on their back
decks this was a trend observed in the
70s in a famous architectural book so
all all of the movement of society is
toward this individualism
with the Advent of computers people
spend a lot more time in their own
little Affinity groups online they don't
spend time with their real Community
they spend time with their virtual
community
then with the Advent of all sorts of new
ideologies which percolate all around
the internet people begin to live
according to different understandings of
reality
most clearly you see this with the
transgender idea in our country right
now we can't even agree on how to know
things what a human being is what are
men what are women we don't agree on
that anymore
we are lit we might occupy the same
geographical area but we are living in
different realities now one of the last
shared things we had was art
and increasingly people don't watch the
same TV shows now we have streaming on
demand people don't watch the same
movies
people just watch movies streaming on
demand and they can be tiny little
movies that that don't have the same box
office numbers that people used to have
even art we now have art on demand
then it really got me thinking you know
you know
what this this AI stuff is in its early
stages but you know once they get it
anywhere near a commercially viable
place
you know it's going to all be porn right
it's like the whole internet it's just
it's all going to be porn and the
scariest part about it is
you can then just make your own porn
and and I was talking with sweet little
Elise about this last night that once
they perfect this AI so that now you can
create these whatever images you want or
even video which they're already working
on previously AI was not that convincing
it's kind of blurry the hands are kind
of a little messed up but within about
six months now it's really really good
the hands are are basically totally
right
once they perfect
the AI technology so that it spreads all
over porn and they perfect sex robots
the human race is going to go extinct
because people are just they're just
going to create
their own fantasies they're just going
to increasingly live in their own
fantasies
what's crazy about this I I promise you
this will happen people will just be
because people are very naughty and we
don't have a lot of restrictions on
society people are going to create porn
of private citizens that they know The
Girl Next Door the
girl and I don't know the girl in math
class or something
it's it's going to be a huge
legal challenge but how do you how do
you put Pandora's Pandora's stuff back
in her box I don't know how you can do
that so the effect I don't mean to just
focus on the weird sex stuff which seems
to dominate our politics these days but
but it's evocative because sex is so
important to the to The Human Condition
and it's such a motivator of our of our
activities but it's true of everything
we're just gonna live
in our own little safe spaces that are
completely concocted within our own
realities
this is what's so troubling to
conservatives about the transgender
ideology
is there's there's no communicating with
someone who says yeah you can never know
what I really believe what I really see
there's no objective truth that we can
communicate about
I just am whatever I say I am and you
have to deal with that so well then that
means that there's nothing objective and
intelligible about the universe it means
that we can't use our faculty as a
reason means we can't govern ourselves
it's just the it's just the total
atomization of society
you see I guess the reason the the porn
aspect of it all stuck out to me is
because porn is such a perversion of the
basic political institution basic
political institution is the marriage
where you give yourself holy to the
other person and your love is so real
with your spouse that it actually
creates a third person
and porn is just the complete inversion
of that
and you and you see that that phenomenon
take place throughout every other level
of
Society we've got
a lot coming up
we have got a woke Tick Tock because
this is woke Wednesday so make sure you
stay tuned for that over the member
block at the Nostradamus member room
segmentum
is it the membrane segment room I don't
know I have to brush up on my Latin
dailyword.com Knowles become a member
use code Knowles at checkout for two
months free on all annual plans
see you over at the member block
[Music]